i heard you're uh starting to crack
emotionally
i mean i guess i don't know
you know i heard you started tearing up
thinking about how much you missed your
best friend john hein
what do you miss most about john hunt oh
i don't know
oh god damage on [ __ ]
well i mean i was just thinking the
other day uh and it hit me that that's
been a while
so uh yeah i haven't seen him in person
in
forever and i like seeing him i like
seeing ronnie uh
you know those two i like being around
uh
so yeah and you started to cry
yeah in fact we asked jd to name the top
three people that he missed most from
the office and he could only
give us two names john hein and ronnie i
i didn't want to start anything you know
if i
went to a third person it would have
started a whole thing of like
what you know i don't want to start any
drama with anyone
give me a third person people get upset
if they're not on your list
yeah that's how popular jd is now oh my
goodness
come on give me a third person uh listen
willa's up there next
uh richard christie is up there uh
sal is up there uh you know other people
all right you know who are you gonna
pick between richard and sal or will
yeah before richard and sam way down on
the list
i love will but you know he's uh he's
like
the big brother type where he uh yeah
i'm starting like
better pick me dude huh you better pick
me a jerk
see this thing this is why you know what
richard christie there you go
[ __ ] where's your krusty [ __ ] you will
who do you like better john heiner
ronnie i think john hines number one
right no no i'm not going there i like
them both
equally for different reasons nah jd
says
john hein holds a special place in my
heart we trust each other and make each
other laugh
he's in love wow yeah
by the way jd's so consumed with death
he said he knows
what he'd talk about at john hines
eulogy like he would tell everyone what
your eulogy would be for john hein
but yeah i just would talk about the the
the you know there's a good good
good man made me laugh and i was good
you said
you said you would talk about his
favorite monty python skit
yes every of his favorite monty python
sketch which is
argument which is the argument clinic
just basically arguing with each other a
little bit but in like a fun way
i got one thing to say though john hein
is the wind beneath my chicken wings
so there right hey john this is taking a
morbid turn
i know that's how some of these
conversations with certain people happen
they take morbid turns very quickly john
would you be interested in jd speaking
at your funeral
is that something or would you rather
have gary i mean those are your two
buddies
i'm really touched by what jd had to say
honestly and uh
all that other things and that's that's
that's pretty sweet
so uh yeah i would love to speak what a
great guy he is john hine
yeah do you feel mutually about jd the
way he feels about you are you uh that
into him
yeah he's a very close friend i treasure
my friendship with jd he's been great
with me since
day one and a lot of people think it's
like a father-son thing
and it's it's not he's he's a good good
friend and i love him dearly no i look
at it more like a mother-daughter thing